on lombarda island in indonesia's
southernmost province
this is mount ili lewatolok
thousands usually live on the slopes of
the volcano accustomed to its quiet
grumbling
close to their homes but days ago a
large eruption triggered panic among the
local population
ash shot more than four kilometers into
the sky
people fled their homes and sought
shelter
i was so scared i fed my goats quickly
and took off to the town
the volcano is still highly active
authorities have closed the nearby
airport
and set up a safety zone
there were still eruptions this morning
every time it happens there's thick
smoke coming from the volcano
emergency shelters are providing food
blankets and medication
we will keep evacuating people in
accordance with the warning the closest
villages could potentially be hit by hot
lava
and volcanic materials local authorities
are also having to deal with the ongoing
health crisis
diarrhea dengue fever and covert 19
we're implementing health protocols in
the camp to stop new virus clusters
forming
the alert for the volcano was raised to
the second highest warning level
and experts on the ground warn against
complacency
according to the data there have been
intense volcanic earthquakes and there
is the potential for more eruptions
indonesia sits on what's known as the
ring of fire
which makes it vulnerable to frequent
seismic activity
it has 147 volcanoes and several
have been highly active this month four
volcanoes across different
islands are now on the second highest
alert level
prompting the evacuations of thousands
of people
authorities here in the capital say they
are closely monitoring the situation
after sensors picked up an increase in
volcanic activity
authorities say the situation is normal
in indonesia in one year normally 10 to
12 volcanoes erupted
can be at the same time can be a
different
time on nabata island the streets are
quiet
and the house is empty people left not
knowing what might remain
when they return jessica washington al
jazeera jakarta